ilhan Omar and Rashida t and a bunch of
others chimed in immediately they had no
evidence that Israel had done anything
here absolutely no evidence it has now
come out completely conclusively that
Israel did not do this we're even going
to show you a video in a moment but
listen to Ilan Omar on Twitter and this
tweet is still up right now bombing a
hospital is among the gravest of war
crimes the IDF reportedly blowing up one
of the few places that injured and
wounded can seek medical treatment and
shelter during a war is horrific pus
president of the United States needs to
push for an immediate ceasefire to end
this Slaughter so she got that tweet out
3:12 p.m. Eastern so it was right as it
happened and all they did on that was
just listen to what Hamas said here's
Rashida Talib other member of the Hamas
caucus Israel just bombed the Baptist
Hospital killing 500 Palestinians she
had no evidence of this doctors
children's patients just like that pus
this is what happens when you refuse to
facilitate a ceasefire and help
deescalate your war and destruction only
approach has opened my eyes and many
Palestinian American and Muslim
Americans like me we remember where you
stood she is an enemy combatant in the
United States we have two we have at
least two I would say AOC is three
there's probably five others with Bowman
members basically who support Hamas
right now in the United States
government so I'll get to the debunking
in just a moment but now check out the
New York Times three times they changed
the headline on this thing here you go
their first headline when they're just
swallowing the Hamas propaganda hole
Israeli strike
uh kills hundreds in hospital
Palestinians say no evidence of it the
Palestinians said it we're a newspaper
all the propaganda that's fit to print
then they changed it a little bit a
little later at least 500 dead in strike
on Gaza Hospital Palestinian state so
now it's not Israeli strike now they
degraded it just to a strike and now
when they found out a little bit more
info uh at least 500 dead in Blast now
it's not a strike because now they
realize it actually wasn't a missile
strike it was a blast uh at Gaza
Hospital uh so before we debunk it I
want to show you something that you have
not seen I know you have not seen it cuz
we didn't even talk about it because
nobody uh saw this uh but on October
11th just last week what's that one week
ago today it was one week ago today
Hamas actually did bomb a hospital in
Israel uh this is barali Hospital in
ashalon Israel and a rocket directly hit
the
hospital
could we double check did uh did ilhan
Omar tweet about that are we able to
check on that one could we uh did
Rashida to anybody maybe maybe her
Twitter is glitching or uh yeah the fact
that I didn't even know about that until
I saw it yesterday right like think
about that here's video and there this
is Al freaking jazer they showing the
rocket going blowing up and then the
shrapnel hitting below and it hits the
hospital
yeah that's Al jazer how often am I
playing Al jazer on here to prove
something I mean Al jazer so you can
what you're seeing there is the rocket
go from Gaza right it's going towards
Israel it blows up some of them they're
they're rudimentary Rockets often made
from pipes that Israel helped import
there to bring in water and it blew up
and the shrapnel and everything else the
payload
hit